foreign
[Music]
to the spectacle the audio spectacle
hello Spectators of the spectacle well
what is it another week of the
situationist international
we're back I'm really excited about this
text but you know I feel
I feel like all the Fizz is out of my
pop so to speak like butter over too
much bread yeah I'm gonna try to I don't
know life
you did just release your new video
right another day another release
speaking of spectacle your camera is
going yeah I don't know what's going on
with that I tried turning it off and on
again I kind of like it I kind of I wish
I could reproduce that effect in After
Effects to The Listener who can't see
him he looks like he's glitching and his
face is turning into my face like uh an
agent from The Matrix yeah it's like uh
some kind of a glitch in The Matrix
happening on my camera over here the
pill is taking you over okay so before
we explain what we're doing today
um I have a book that I have read and
found and forgot about when we started
this because we wanted to read Society
of spectacle right
and a lot of what we were anticipating
and kind of what we'll go over again
today was
they were they were ready to come by
1968. these guys were going so hard they
thought Modern Art modern video new
Theory we're going to change all that
energy went into 68 and it kind of
explains the disappointment after but
Deborah also wrote a book on his own
book afterwards it's called it's called
comments on the Society of spectacle
yeah so I thought yeah if we if we try
to burn through the Society of spectacle
book
then it might be fun to read
his hindsight because I I have read it
and I have no idea what it says I
completely forgot that I even possessed
it
but it would be interesting to hear
his post-revolution post-failed
Revolution thoughts compared to his
pre-revolution thoughts the post-coital
spectacle that's interesting I think
he's deepened his position on that the
spectacle is taking over
I actually clipped out a quote from it
he said spectacular domination has
succeeded in raising an entire
generation molded to its laws so what he
writes in the later book
1988. yeah in comments in 1988 he wrote
that he's he thinks we're just like
deep in the Matrix now
so to recap last week a little bit
Revolution needs this I mean what I read
today I'll explain in a sec we read
different things but what I read today
sounds so much like a Twitter Marxist or
a Twitter Anarchist it's like we it's
like we're just repeating the loop that
we're stuck on and they wrote it pre-68.
so I found that fascinating but they're
kind of saying we need a truly
revolutionary subjectivity
this is a bit recap but we need to
revolutionize everyday life we can't
just change jobs to labor unions to
syndicates we need like
we need TV that is revolutionary and our
in our world that is revolutionary
we need revolutionary subjectivity no
yeah exactly exactly as compared to
altuzaire which is the big distinction
we're we're drawing which is new I
haven't I haven't considered it in these
terms before
but the the board side is humanist marks
we need like a a we need to remake the
world
and a REV Revolt the subject whereas all
twos there is far more or less about the
subject I should say he's very much like
the subject is a product of the system
and not vice versa so it's a it's an
interesting debate to rehash and one
that I didn't even know was a debate and
that famous and Infamous line uh what is
it like history is without a subject or
something so I don't know uh are you
going first pills or well yeah I don't
explain what we're doing to to cover
more ground because if you go to the
there's going to be a link but if you go
to the SI archive which is a big website
it's got so many my camera is so
distracting I'm sorry I know I'm trying
not to look at it
I feel like you should edit it out and
use it in one of your future videos yeah
okay because you're you're taking the
video of this right that'd be funny I
wanted to I want to take the uh the
effect and try to reproduce it but
anyway we wanted to cover more ground
because so much of what they write is in
little articles like pamphlets uh little
little films and movies and stuff so we
thought we would do what you do in a
grad seminar and you split up the work
where everybody reads and then you try
to teach teach each other what it said
so we're gonna split this into three
each of us chose our own thing following
our own interests to read yeah and I I
guess I'll go I'll go because it's kind
of a segue from last week I read
the revolution of Modern Art and the
Modern Art of revolution
so there's still they're still working
on art
and kind of like I said they're they are
so hopeful it's a it's something I'm
jealous for because this was written
particularly in 1967. so one year before
and it makes a lot more sense to me
having read this
why 68 was such a big deal for so many
of not just the S.I but so many like
Marxist young academics theorists and
artists because they had they had the
biggest hard on you could get they were
ready to go then the strikes started uh
you got the workers in the streets you
got the students in the streets and then
it all comes to nothing because of the
neolib cave-in depending on your
perspective
so
um my so there's a lot of optimism yeah
it's it's like
one of the quotations I I could just
give you a sense of what this reading is
like one of the quotations is like we
don't need to
burn the Louvre
we need to sack the Louvre and then burn
it
like we we need to get out in the
streets
um and a lot of it it doesn't sound that
foreign another quotation is like the
game now is the destruction of the
Sacred whether it be the sanctity of
Jesus or the sanctity of the electric
mixer
tragedy says lucach is a game played in
the sight of godlessness the true form
of godlessness will be the final
achievement of Revolution the end of the
illusory and all its forms the beginning
of real life and its direct
self-consciousness
hmm yeah that's interesting does it it
almost sounds a bit accelerationist
Stephen yeah I think you could say that
there it's like we need to get rid of
all the old we need to get rid of this
culture of that lives in the death or
the shadow of the death of God
um we need to get rid of all illusion
and then everything will
look better for us
you know well it's like it's optimistic
in the sense that like this is possible
but it's also quite I mean for now it
it's very cynical in the sense that
we're in the midst of commodity
capitalism and everything is suspect
but something else is possible
so there's that that optimism combined
with an extraordinary kind of skepticism
towards
every structure of modern society yeah
well my my tragic the tragic irony I
found was like they want to destroy
Christianity there's Christianity is the
enemy on one hand and capitalism on the
other our market capitalism so he says
like we need to destroy the The Cult of
the electric mixer like the the kitchen
KitchenAid thingy and what does he mean
by that
that everyone is either still living in
the past or they are just comfortable
living among their commodities
right so I can't have like uh Creature
Comforts anymore in this situation is
Utopia like I can't just have like a
dishwasher or things that make my life
easier I mean you could you can have
them you just are are supposed to want
for more
right I think I think we're becoming
like just satiated by those things to
never want anything more right and the
task of the artist and theorist is then
to somehow make people want more
right but the tragic irony I found is
like that seems right he wants to he
wants to destroy Christianity and
tradition and whatever and our belief in
liberalism
and I shouldn't even say he is multiple
authors
but uh
the thing is like capitalism not not
necessarily capitalism but at least our
media ecology and the internet I think
it has destroyed Christianity and
tradition as you know a universal
Foundation just not
with the with the Revolutionary
potential to point towards afterwards
that he that they were they were hoping
for yeah I was gonna say I feel like all
those things are being destroyed or
destroyed continuing to be destroyed
regardless
um but I guess they're being replaced by
this other kind of spectacle right of
like consumer capitalism and all this
other stuff yeah it's not like they're
totally you know they they quote like
Martin Luther King quite you know
approvingly and his whole thing is to
bring that sort of Southern Christian
Catholic uh organization to the north to
try and alleviate poverty
and uh and uh and like wealth gaps
so it's not like they're they're against
it they're against it in so far as it
becomes a kind of mouthpiece of the
spectacle of the of the dominant class
where the spectacle captures and then
uses it parrots through kind of you know
when you get commentary from from
Christians and and and Cardinals and
stuff on various events they often just
sort of
you know they they deplore violence they
deplore rioting like they they but they
they deploy this approbation in such a
way that the people who are rising up
are the ones who are the target of these
of this censure
so they end up just like these these
types of people whereas like Martin
Luther King who they cite approvingly is
is is not one of the targets right if
you have this might be the case it's not
in this text but it might be the case
that if you have a religion with a
revolutionary outcome then they're
willing to keep it around
but obviously in in
Paris and France they're probably
speaking of conservative Catholicism I
would suppose yeah like insofar as it's
it's it's a bulwark against anything
that's going to disturb the commodity
structure of society then they're
against it that's the whole idea right
like destroying whatever destroying the
electric mixer that's a commodity it's
exchange value that is completely
subordinated use value
that's the sort of like there's like a
the that background of Marx's Theory
where you have use value and exchange
value but exchange value comes to the
four and use value becomes secondary
yeah they also are opposed to Wonder
Bread so I I assume that in their world
they would like to go back to a world of
social
related Commodities because Commodities
are actually social relations where you
very in a very French fashion you go out
to the bakery at the beginning of the
week and you get your your breads
and that's that's a true social relation
as opposed to buying Wonder Bread yeah
yeah I mean
they're just they're kind of just like
snobby elitists really who just like
hate anything that's like mass produced
I mean elitist might be the wrong word
yeah like a lot of it is about
institutions they're anti-elitist and
right they're anti-elitists
they are all about those happenings and
teach-ins that go beyond the bounds of
academic discourse they're they're
anti-elitist they're they're
anti-hierarchy in a certain way yeah I
mean we can
uh like on my reading of at least the
thing that I read I kind of I've
constructed a little bit of an argument
for why I think like they kind of are
unintentional elitists but we can we can
put a pin in that until later
they just want everyday life to be
connected to Labor Relations
as it was in a perhaps nostalgic past
free us from submission to capitalism
and the commodity
what do you make of the claim because
it's something I mean I don't know where
we want to go in this discussion or if
you have more to say uh about this piece
that you read pills oh I got a ton of
notes okay well I don't know if you why
don't you ask a question that's a good
way to keep going well the question I
have is more just about the claim
which is something that came up in my
reading too
um it seems like there's a there's this
idea of like mediation uh under
underlying their entire critique
that the spectacle is somehow
um mediating us to like a less authentic
form of human expression and creativity
and that like there was or there's an
implication that there was a time when
we were I don't know and it sounds kind
of nietzschean to me like living life
directly you know there's this kind of
Claim about
some there's some kind of like activism
or something about uh that I'm a little
unsure about and I guess I just
I have a lot of trouble with those kinds
of Clan those kinds of nostalgia claims
like I think there's just different
kinds of mediation but I think like
subjectivity itself is the process of
like an unavoidable mediation where
we're kind of alienated from ourselves
regardless of what the cultural cultural
structure is
like whether we're in a tribal Society
there's going to be all kinds of
mystifications that come from as a
result of those folk traditions
and then there's going to be a different
kind of mediation and I think you could
make an argument that the mediation
that's happening now as a result of of
mass capitalism is like worse for
various reasons but I don't know if it's
any more mediated or at least I'm a
skeptic about that I don't think it's
it's not about you know going back or
Nostalgia right because that just kind
of assumes that capitalism is the most
advanced and we can't go forward Beyond
it I think that would be a bad
assumption to make because obviously
Marx's theory is built on this getting
past it yeah no it's totalizing but you
know here's like you know just as just
as
just as social relations among workers
who are alienated come to be mediated by
the products that confront them in the
market now what he's always kind of
turning Marxist phrases like this now he
says in aphorism 4 from the spectacle
Society of the spectacle the spectacle
is not a collection of images it is a
social relation between people that is
mediated by images now so instead of
Commodities it's images that mediate our
relationships and I I don't want to go
give them away I watched that film and
as this text is going over in the in the
voiceover there's pictures of crowds of
people staring back at the camera and
you get your idea of social relations
from the spectacle which represents them
to you and you are told how social
relationship it's building on this idea
that social relations are objectified
and we are alienated from the products
of our labor which then mediate our
social relations over and against us as
they confront Us in the market this is
now the image Market the spectacle right
so I I think I have no problem with that
kind of an analysis right like I think
that that's like a specific analysis and
that does come up but I think the thing
that rubs me the wrong way is is any
sort of claim towards living life more
directly or something like that like so
what's their positive account and that
was really the question I had
it's just like what is this what are
they talking about when they say that
let's get to that in the critique part I
guess okay I want to agree with your
initial response because it's also my
initial response that we should be
hesitant to believe like okay now
everything's bad and then before
everything was okay or better because
you can say of course everything every
every primitive ceremony uh religion is
very much mediated by you know a
different kind of image at least or
images and ceremony and fantasy and
simulacra exactly it always is but I
think there's also the case to be made
that ours is worse yeah I like I think I
said in my response that I'm open to
that right but I just don't like this
language of and I'm not even talking
about going back like that there's a
chronological claim here but even the
idea that you could live more directly
with like some authentic core
I just don't really buy that I just
think there's different kinds of
relationships that we can have to each
other they're all going to be mystified
in different ways I just don't think
that there's a more authentic true one
and in some ways it would just be less
alienated that's what all it would be
maybe unalienate do you not see a
difference between buying a
or getting a a Walmart Wonder Bread like
delivered to your house as opposed to
going to the bakery of the guy who baked
it
yes of course I think that that I think
that there's a difference there but I
don't know if there's like uh like I
guess I was reading the claim more as a
claim about
subjectivity
like that that subjectivity will change
to be like more in touch
with some with I don't know something
that's the thing that I'm not sure about
no that's that's a critique I'll make
but I'm gonna make it in a long ass way
if that's okay okay so I picked this
piece it's called The Modern Art of
Revolution and revolution of Modern Art
they're really into art and they just
say Art's only getting worse and they
said this in the 60s so they said like
we had the dadaists the datas the
dataists uh pushed it a little bit the
surrealists pushed a little bit but then
they all became institutionalized and
gave up and [__] them so we need a new
thing and the new thing that we got
in actual fact was
uh Modern Art moving to America and
becoming like Andy Warhol and Jeff Coons
and Britain as well
and moving away from
from Paris is the center of the art
world but I want to like what they're
going for is I think they believe a
little bit too much this would be my
pushback they think that this capitalism
thing is external rather than internal
and they understand it's internal but
they kind of think all right we could we
could Purge it out yeah so I want to
make a comparison here because I picked
this
because you know I love Mad Men the show
um I love bernay's well I don't love
Bernard I love I love that Bernays was
like we can hack the unconscious using
Freud and advertise [__] to people uh we
got we got delis in there so on the
other side of the Atlantic we have MK
Ultra doing its thing at the same time
they're they're basically looking for
how far can we go down the mind to hack
the subconscious and turns out it's
pretty complicated doesn't really work
but they're trying to control the
unconscious whereas these guys they're
trying to do their own hack but they're
trying to do their hack for a very
different end to like awaken it to the
totality of of social relations that are
are obfuscated or turned into
images
so it's no longer a believable belief to
us but still fascinating maybe it is
believable I shouldn't say that I
shouldn't dismiss it it's it's hard for
me to believe I'll say
um but this detour and malt that Eric
was talking about last week or
reappropriation of AD images
and they thought this was capable of so
much and it's still a relevant question
I think for today because you know we
have a
pretty online audience I would say maybe
less colonized than most people on the
internet because some of them still read
books once in a while but you know quite
online and we're helping to decolonize
them
well I don't know I don't know for
helping anything
decolonizing themselves mostly I know I
know but I just mean like the the
leftist
influencers or Marx tick tocks they
probably still maintain this kind of
hope and us too I guess we're not doing
it for no reason and I feel like aren't
there some people in our in our audience
who are kind of like that no
that we have the hope for a future media
that's different
yeah the hope
yeah maybe yeah yeah sure I mean what a
I mean what is Hope why why do anything
without it I don't know I don't know
it's it's there's a lot of quippy lines
out there about it I hope is an illusion
I don't know well the question is really
for the at least in this article what
does it take to produce
Consciousness and what does it take to
make a new Consciousness because for
them they they actually go through a
summary of Modern Art it's uh very
interesting to me perhaps less
interesting to other people but the
summary of it is like art was always
classist it was always about the great
military victories only the only the
aristocrats are allowed into the
military for a long ass time then you
have like portraiture and patrons so
it's always been really classist until
the Dutch Renaissance and if you know
anything about the Dutch Renaissance
they start painting
you know random rooms and random crowds
of people that are not Aristocrats and
uh work boots is something that
Heidegger gets all excited about so you
have this like
you have this mediation of not just
aristocratic life but also
lower class life or General Life
and they say that this movement in art 2
was nihilistic because you are just
you're preserving it in something that
can only still be consumed by
Aristocrats you put it in the Louvre you
put it into galleries rich people buy it
and they store it in
in a little storage lockers in airports
so they don't have to pay taxes on it
which is all art has become these days
but they say
art is on a repetitive Loop and we need
to get it out of this repetitive Loop
they have a good quotation it's like
each repetition is feebler and more
inane than the last only today with the
first signs of a more highly evolved
Revolt within a highly developed
capitalism can the radical project of
Modern Art be taken up again and taken
up coherently
so they're yeah they're about to come
they're about to take art away from the
bourgeoisie and uh that's the new game
for them yeah I mean I it's there's a
lot of overlap uh with what I read too
because I think that's a interesting key
claim
about how how can you change
Consciousness and I guess
they seem to have a belief which I'm not
sure if you totally fleshed out in your
summary about like how it is exactly at
least that art is supposed to do this
um I don't know if there's like a a
fully drawn out
theory of how art can change
Consciousness I mean I kept thinking
about phenomenology too because I feel
like that's relevant to this question of
like how is
how is the effect of art able to somehow
like disrupt or change subjectivity I
mean I think that's I mean it seems like
their political project depends on
a fairly robust belief in the power that
art could potentially have on the masses
right
I should say though it's also not just
like
art as in making paintings because you
got to think this is the 60s people
don't have television in their homes yet
right so when they're talking about
advertising they're basically talking
about Outdoor Advertising uh maybe
there's advertisements before you see a
film or something like that maybe not
I'm not sure but there's not like Mass
advertising is still in in the public
space so if you draw that distinction it
makes sense for them to think we just
need to take over the public space we
need to replace the ad with for a mixer
with something like ironic or
revolutionary or or something that
challenges creativity and Imagination
and that will produce it differently so
I mean the fact that we just sit in bed
before we go to sleep and consume
advertisements
uh every hour of the day privately I
think that that the puts a nail in this
belief but they thought you know we
could just take over the public space
and that's where Consciousness is
created that's where public is created
and why not why couldn't we do that
yeah it's interesting you know it almost
I think I brought this up actually this
guy actually up last week or last
episode too
you know it's not quite the same thing
but it's interesting that in both
episodes about situationism this guy
Dave meslin who's this like local kind
of activist in Toronto who just always
argues how we should be
how the public space should
be also shared with messages
that are about some concept of the
public good like
you know even even just like to
encourage people to go participate in
like their local politics let's say they
should he's like we should have a third
of all ad space be dedicated to
encouraging the public to become better
citizens basically right that like for
every ad there should be an ad that says
this meeting is happening in your
neighborhood about this building right
like even something as local as like you
should come out right and like use admin
and use the that psychology to get
people I mean that's different than what
they're saying but I think there's still
an interesting claim there about
the use of public space yeah for a
purpose the power that it could have
right for both worse and better and
needs to be stressed I think that what
they were saying wasn't really
impossible like if you had enough people
you could quite easily sabotage every
public advertisement in town because
there weren't that many of them
but I guess the issue that I have is
today
you have
I don't know a kind of naive online
revolutionary quote unquote who is
saying the same thing as them but what
it would take to take over advertising
right now
for us it's it's impossible it could
never happen you'd have to take over
every social media platform you'd have
to be the one serving the ads on the
social media platform like do people
even look at Outdoor Advertising anymore
or are they kind of like walking with
their phone in their hand
so what do you think I want to say I
just want to say that it's it it's
really not stupid what they were saying
it was like conceivable in a way that's
inconceivable now
yeah I mean do you think though that
it's that like
Madonna are you sure that it's re it was
realistic even back then just to I mean
because they were saying I mean it
sounded like they they had a bit of a of
a burn it all down attitude similar to
the way that I think some of these
online marxists and anarchists
yeah but I think May 68 they took over
most of the city center if you're like
failed if you're if you're taking well
they took it over yeah right gave it up
but if you take over the whole city
center you can easily pull down all the
advertisements or or sabotage them all
so then what about what's different
today the internet
yeah I mean you you'd have to you'd have
to take over things that can't be taken
over
I mean you got hackers
you're gonna hack Instagram I don't know
if I don't know sure I mean send
anonymous an email or something see what
they're doing they're they're hacking
governments and dumping private
information online it's not it's not a
bad thing right increase transparency
use the internet the way it's supposed
to be used don't use it to sell more
[__] to people and make more money
and profit [__] that
but that's how it's going to be used
under the current system
and they give examples as well
um that are applicable in terms of like
they said uh the sexual Revolution for
example happened because of film in
large part like the Catholic church
trying to determine
what what who can have sex with who and
when and marriage and all this stuff
that kind of just it was eroded and
dissolved and we could say the same
thing maybe about uh views of the gays
or things in our media space it's just
like you can you can make you can change
things by showing it to people yeah the
gays with a y not with the Z gay right
okay right I don't know why you're
laughing about this because the gays are
trying to make your kids gay and on the
other hand you have d and d and
Metallica and Pantera who are trying to
make your kids go sacrifice chickens in
the forest at night yeah well we kind of
take it for granted but back then it was
a struggle I don't think it's funny
homosexuality and and and other forms of
sexuality were
were really really not accepted
generally it was a struggle the sexual
Liberation movement was a huge struggle
and now we were reaping the benefits of
it somewhat somewhat not all there
but it's easy to take the progress
that's been gained for granted as if it
just came out of this benevolent system
of neoliberal capitalism it didn't come
from them it did not come from them but
they are happy to sell us analube and
dildos yeah they're definitely now that
we've now that we got the taste for
flesh and blood
but yeah I remember there's actually I
mean at people capitalists are so quick
to co-opt any new movement that they can
I remember in my in a past life
when I was like a terrible student and
did Community College for a little while
and was studying business marketing I
remember
this would have been
in like the early 2010 like 2008 or 2007
like a long time ago and I remember
I feel like LGBT ads were kind of a bit
of a new thing and I think one of the
cases they talked about was how Subaru
was like they noticed that their
demographic was like a lot of lesbian
women were buying Subarus
and how they realized it it was an
opportunity and it took a while but they
made like one of the first ads that
initially was just kind of covertly
advertising to to lesbian women and like
only you would only realize it if you
were a lesbian and then later became
more overtly like the Subaru
Forester or I forget whatever the
station wagon for whatever reason it
became like
the lesbian car yeah I bet that was a
spiritual struggle for them they
probably had to spend a few extra
minutes in the confession booth for that
one
anyway I think that's it for my article
um I guess the points that the takeaways
that I wanted to make were
it seemed like a lot less work than now
so it's understandable why they had so
much hope
right they thought that the new art the
new art form is gonna be outside of the
museums we're gonna we're gonna loot the
museums and put all the old art like in
the streets we can sabotage
advertisements we can put up our own
advertisements and uh this can create a
new
they call it Urban Consciousness like a
cities a city's Consciousness and
creating the city in the form that
serves life here is what they say is
like the the Revolutionary art project
is to create a city
and yeah that came up in my article too
interesting stuff and it's just so yeah
I I don't want to be too too uh
I think our Revolution will take place
on a different scale or at a different
level because I can't imagine enough
people going out to the streets to uh
change the city anymore at least this
kind of cities that we live in but you
know it's a
respect
they saw they saw all the problems they
did
yeah I mean like things like like
rioting and and Revolution and
demonstration
like I don't they're not I don't think
they're meant to directly change things
they're meant to awaken a kind of class
Consciousness and reveal the
contradictions because when things are
going smoothly those contradictions Fade
Into the background and when one group
or another it's not like Revolution just
kind of happens to the
the colorless the colorless jobless
historical subject it's always kind of
specific whatever group Rises up it
reveals those contradictions
and the point of their their totalizing
view of things right is to put those
contradictions in a global into Global
Perspective rather than looking at them
as like isolated and and uh and
anomalous they put them into that that
sort of lucachian hegelian totality
said the word and I think I said it too
but this totality totality almost to us
as I guess post-structuralist to some
degree it sounds like something scary or
something bad totalization right but
they're they want totality as opposed to
the absolute fragmentation of social
relations like you go to work you're a
producer you come home you're a consumer
and this is the these splits between
people and the splits in yourself those
are the things that they want to
totalize in order to uh reunify but
anyway I think that's enough for me why
don't we turn to you Eric and you can
present what you read
yeah well the totalizing is relevant for
what I'm gonna be talking about too
um
because yeah it's it's still so much
when you when you look at say sort of
post-marxists and and and other Marxist
thinkers the the ways that they they
engage in polemics with post-modernists
and post-structuralists and sooner or
later total totality is probably going
to come into it it still seems to be
like a line of Separation it's like no
your theory is is a totalizing theory we
don't want to be told we are committed
to local the local the micro
it always seems to be like a point of um
separation
on the great on the great Plinko Board
of leftist theories it's one of the pegs
but anyway my article is about
um
the 1965 Watts Riots uh in Los Angeles
this is Guido board's take on the Los
Angeles
riots
that occurred in 1965 in Los Angeles
it's got a complicated history that I
don't really think
I could possibly do justice too was he
did he go there or is he just writing
about this from Paris
he's I mean it says this was translated
in into English and distributed in the
USA in 1965 December the riots started
in August so I imagine it's a kind of
pamphlet and it was quickly written and
distributed but probably from across the
pond
I think that's just what they do right
they're like a modern Marxist movement
like they see labor strikes they see
revolutions they see right they just
they just insert themselves into it and
start start saturating it with their
their theorizing that's right this is
from 1965. so remember this is the post
1962 phase where art was de-prioritized
and theory was prioritized saying theory
is what's gonna help carry us forward
right so we're at the board section so
pamphlet Wars but I mean there is still
the pamphlet Wars and the whole
Manifesto genre anyway let me stop
Tristram shandying this narrative and
just get right into it
um
I mean something like the thesis of this
of this pamphlet is like
here's here's a line for you okay and
all those who went so far is to
recognize the scare quotes apparent
justifications of the Rage of the Los
Angeles blacks that's how he's going to
refer to them blacks and whites
um
but never they're real justifications
never the real justifications I should
say behind this Riot they pay homage the
spectacle does to the quote-unquote real
justifications all the ideologists and
spokesmen of the vacuist international
left deployed the irresponsibility the
disorder the Looting especially the fact
that arms and alcohol were the first
targets and the 2000 fires with which
the blacks lit up their battle and their
ball
but who has defended the Los Angeles
rioters in the terms they deserve we
will nice let the French let the issue
yeah yeah yeah step it up like I like
the spirit and he says next let the
economists fret over their lost 27
million dollars and the city planners
sigh over one of their most beautiful
supermarkets got up at smoke and the
McIntyre blubber over his slain deputy
sheriff let the sociologists bemoan the
absurdity and the intoxication of this
Rebellion the role of a revolutionary
publication like ours is not only to
justify the Los Angeles insurgents with
the help elucidate their perspectives to
explain theoretically the truth for
which such practical action expresses
the search so you could imagine why this
was a pamphlet since a couple months
later
six days of rioting
over three thousand arrests surprisingly
around 32 deaths most of them most of
them from the black community many of
them cops accidentally shooting each
other while in the struggles
um
interesting Parts yeah so he writes this
pamphlet and it's his take on all of
this and that I I read that part out
because I think that's more or less the
thesis
uh it started it is this was like a
precursor if you remember like the
Rodney King riots La 1991 I believe it
was
um black man beaten on the Highway by a
cop somebody they pull him over drag him
out beat him someone gets it on tape
causes riots very similar situation here
a rookie cop pulls over what he thought
was an intoxicated man
he was black he had a
person in the car they rent they were
near the house so they went and got
their mother and dragged their mother
back over got into an altercation as
this was happening huge crowd was
starting to form to watch and then from
there
rumors spread especially one rumor that
the cops kicked a pregnant lady wasn't
there a ride after Rodney King too yeah
this one was like
30 30 years before that yeah so this was
like the OG La Riot can you correct like
were you saying when you were reading
this that
the international left was like decrying
this and being like oh they shouldn't
Riot yeah yeah
well the left second repeating itself
yeah no it's always the same thing right
people who call themselves leftists
people who call themselves liberals but
as soon as somebody comes and tries to
stand up for what they want what they
need
what they think they deserve they call
them irresponsible they say you have no
Solutions you have no positive vision of
the future right you're just Rascals and
Scoundrels burning and destroying and
making things worse for everybody that's
always the lines right and the the
Christians drop on that yeah we draw the
line at burning down a Wendy's yeah
exactly like we you know I don't I don't
like I don't like slavery I don't like
wealth disparities but we draw the line
when you rob a furniture store like when
like I don't I don't know what the logic
there is but that's true that's the
logic of the spectacle is what it is
really to be fair I think I think most
leftist critiques of rioting are are not
like oh I draw the line here but are
more coming from a place of is this the
strategically prudent way
or is this going to make us look worse I
mean and I think that's like a
reasonable worry yeah sure but I mean
it's it's black people in America in
this case it's their real history and
real grievances that have long long long
and still continue to this day but
that's that's besides the point have
gone unaddressed and as soon as you know
they try to address them they try to
address them they do the non-violent
thing they protest exactly what Martin
Luther King likes right he says the same
thing he says you know I don't like the
violence non-violent right he wants to
lead strikes he wants to lead marches
but he wants them to be non-violent he
wants them to stand there take the
beating and then stand back and take the
moral High Ground that's how he wants to
approach the situations
so he's not but he's not like the target
it's the target is the these
what's the word approbius leftists the
Centrist leftists that say you know
these people are out of line the libs
yeah these people are out of line but
he's got that's why he's got apparent
justifications and scare quotes because
he's what's the real justification for
these riots
decades and decades and Decades of
mistreatment I mean second-class citizen
Jim Crow laws right this is
1900 to 1970 was called The Great
Migration which is the largest internal
migration in any country in the history
of the world six million black people
came up to the northern states from the
south that's part of the background of
this that's why I said I couldn't do it
justice there's so much [__] going on
and plus World War II
the drafting
there's there's so many backgrounds to
this you just have to read something up
on if you want to get the background of
the watch rights but
so what he's saying here is he's he's
defending the rioters
he's saying it's not a racial conflict
it was not a racial conflict this is now
we're setting it in the totalizing frame
the Watts Riot he says was not a racial
conflict
the rioters left alone the whites that
were in their path attacking only the
white policemen while on the other hand
black solidarity did not extend to Black
store owners or even black car drivers
Martin Luther King himself had to admit
that the Revolt went beyond the limits
of his specialty speaking in Paris last
October
he said this was not a race riot it was
a class riot
and he's going to make the point that
white working-class Americans need to
make common cause with with the black
liberation movement in the United States
because they are the most advanced
I guess in terms of subjectivity they
they are the most advanced in all modern
society because they are the ones whose
situation best reveals the
contradictions of capital
which is where the way that the
commodity form
farts out hierarchies wherever it goes
wherever it achieves
dominance it creates hierarchies it's a
lower class in the upper class
the ones I don't know who can direct and
bend the spectacle to
capture capture it towards their
interests and the ones who are just
simply subject to this alienation
of the commodity world of which the
spectacle is a kind of emanation of
developed commodity capitalism so does
he get into it all when he's saying like
this is not a race conflict it's a class
conflict
to see it all go into
the the spectacleization of the event
because presumably he's getting this
through
news media just the same as everybody
else's right
he's it's being mediated by images is
what I'm saying yeah I mean
[Music]
yeah I mean he's here's what he sort of
says about that
he asks a rhetorical well maybe not it's
a question how do people make history
under conditions designed to dissuade
them from intervening in it
Los Angeles blacks are better paid than
any others in the United States but they
are also the most separated from the
California super opulence that is
flaunted all around them Hollywood the
pull of the global spectacle is right
next door
they are promised that with patience
they will join in America's Prosperity
but they come to see that this
Prosperity is not a fixed state but an
endless ladder the higher they climb the
farther they get from the top because
they start off disadvantaged because
they are less qualified and thus more
numerous among the unemployed and
finally because the hierarchy that
crushes them is not based on economic
buying power alone they are also treated
as inherently inferior and in a way what
he's saying next too is that the
spectacle needs the black communities of
the United States in order to I think
with the one hand put all the worst
qualities onto them and other them
and on the other hand show how how
beneficent capitalism is look we can
alleviate poverty look how powerful the
system is at improving people's lives it
also does that white people only suffer
under the commodity but black people
negate it with in their situation he
says they're negating the commodity
because of black people he drops n-bombs
in this too I'm not going to repeat them
but he says you know they can only be
rich because blacks as a whole must
represent poverty in a society of
hierarchized wealth they must represent
poverty every Witness
noted the cry proclaiming the global
significance of the uprising quote
within quote this is a black Revolution
and we want the world to know it
so it's you know this pamphlet has this
sort of inflammatory kind of interesting
language as I was yelling about earlier
when I was yelling out what I thought
was basically the thesis of it
but yeah they're the
they are needed in a certain way by the
spectacle in order for it to justify
itself which is a very interesting
dialectical way of thinking about these
about riots which is which runs against
the grain of sort of
yeah I don't know what you call it
neoliberal thinking can you explain that
one quotation you just gave what does it
mean to say that they negate the
commodity is it because they're breaking
the commodity during the riots or is it
because of something
older let me see this explains it a
little bit but not a whole lot
um
the references to it are a little
scattered
in in taking the capitalist spectacle
at its face value the blacks are already
rejecting the spectacle itself that was
a quote
continues the spectacle is a drug for
slaves it is designed not to be taken
literally but to be followed
from just Out Of Reach
when this separation is eliminated the
hoax is revealed in the United States
today the whites are enslaved to the
commodity I misquoted that earlier
the whites are enslaved to the commodity
while the blacks are negating it the
blacks are asking for more than the
whites this is the core of core of a
problem that has no solution except the
dissolution of the white social system
this is why those whites this is what I
was saying earlier quote this is why
those whites who want to escape their
own slavery must first of all rally to
the black Revolt not obviously in racial
solidarity but in a joint Global
rejection of the commodity and of the
state man how how the F how [__]
history repeats itself
I know it's a he it's cast in racial
terms but the whites are enslaved to it
in the fact that they never give it up
whereas the black community in La that's
revolting they are negating the form of
it and you see the same thing in the uh
defund the police versus versus uh Thin
Blue Line Mega heads
is like you're not getting any richer in
this system your kids are not going to
be any richer they're going to be the
same as you or worse but they have no no
vocabulary of resistance oh my God if
you wanna yeah black lives matter and
the defund the police movement listen to
this [__] line what is a policeman
the board asks what is a policeman
answers his own question he is the
active servant of the commodity the man
in complete submission to the commodity
whose job it is to ensure that a given
product of human labor remains a
commodity with the magical property of
having to be paid for instead of
becoming a mere refrigerator or rifle a
passive inanimate object subject to
anyone who comes along to make use of it
there's the use value thing and when he
says mere refrigerator or rifle he means
looting he means when you steal it when
you don't pay for it he says because he
says looting is a natural response to
the unnatural and inhuman Society of
commodity abundance that that again
that's spectacle right the spectacle
informs the commodity it presents the
commodity world to us but it stays just
Out Of Reach we follow it and follow it
and follow it we never reach it it's
inhuman it's a false promise the
humanism of the spectacle is a is a
salve that keeps us numb and stupid and
unwilling to intervene on behalf of
other people who are really fighting for
the same things that we should be
fighting for unless your last name is
Sinclair or Rockefeller or Trump or
someone like that if it is [__] you if
not then get involved that's the whole
point and would you say the the date on
this was 1962.
60 65 yeah or 60 66 that was reprinted
and published in in um at one of those
in situationist um
for their Journal publication I guess
Mark but it was originally written yeah
a couple months after the riots right so
we're in August 13th the 16th 1965.
a few years before Martin Luther King
was shot well that is three years before
May
1968. that is based
like what I'm getting out of this is it
seems like we're just Reinventing the
wheel having the same debates over and
over again and almost as if like oh
we're finally figuring it out when this
was written when like my dad wasn't born
yet pretty much yeah and this is an
amazing sort of Defense you know when
when we had that recent
sort of outbreak of of of violence sort
of you know
uh the Watts rise Rodney King and then
we had our our modern day one that the
Millennials get to experience got to
experience which one was the same it's
the same sort of thing right yeah the
Floyd oh yeah okay yeah yeah and the
same sorts of things happened right
rioting and then the same then the
spectacle deployed its same rhetoric
look at these irresponsible people look
how they're stealing from good
hard-working people like they deployed
the exact same rhetoric that he's
debunking here
and he's defending but he's defending
the rioting and the destruction and the
looting in in very
mid-century Marx's terms when he says
something like um
people who destroy Commodities show
their human superiority over Commodities
they stop submitting to the arbitrary
forms that distortedly reflect their
real needs the Flames of Watts
consummated the system of consumption
the theft of refrigerators by people
with no electricity or with their
electricity cut off is the best image of
the LIE of affluence transformed into a
truth in play once it is no longer
bought the commodity lies open to
criticism and alteration whatever
particular form it may take only when it
is paid for that's what I was saying the
magic of the commodity right must be
paid for police defend that police are
the Defenders of property that's what
comes up in the defund the police
movement right that's all they are
they're they're outgrowth of pinkertons
and various sort of human property
protectors now they're commodity
property protectors
they they uh they serve it's it's really
it's uncanny this these I I love the
spirit of this
though's response is like what about the
poor what about the small business owner
like no small business owners are very
few and far between compared to like a
Walmart being looted
you know if a Walmart gets looted it's
okay no it's just it's just things I
mean I mean to be fair though like I
mean I do think that where the Watts
Riot happened as well as like the LA
riots and as well as even some of the
neighborhoods where uh like some of the
stuff that happened more recently
like a lot of this stuff happened in in
like poor neighborhoods where the people
who were running the businesses were
more likely to be like a black
low-income it's into the spectacle over
here uh that's good
that's what he said here he said it was
a class thing it wasn't a race thing
right yeah assuming the race the the
Riders were racialized and then we're so
confused when they attack store owners
who are also a visible minority because
that's not what it's about it's a class
thing yeah no totally that seems like
that seems like a fair analysis I'm more
just in response to
you know when I hear some leftists be
like you know who cares about like the
like they imagine that the people that
are being affected by the Looting are
just like big like white suits and I'm
just saying that's not always I'm not
saying that it's even my objection my
objection is that the only thing NBC
will talk about is the poor the poor
business owners who's like their windows
are getting smashed
but here's actually something here's
kind of actually something kind of
interesting that might be different from
back then to now
it's like I would say that now the media
like there was a divide in the media
like the liberal mainstream media was
largely defending the riots like and and
the and the conservative media was the
one that was because I mean there's even
that famous clip that conservatives just
love to replay where like it's like some
reporter standing in front of like a
bunch of flames behind them and they're
like it's mostly just peaceful protests
here and it's just like you know they
show that
so I think there was a difference I
think that back then in the 60s
the media probably was much more
overwhelmingly just being against the
rights I think today protests you see
you have a lot more of a mix of views
from the from the mainstream media I
don't have any factual evidence to
confirm or deny but I think we should uh
move on so that Victor gets his shot
here yeah I mean I'm not look I'm not
saying that the mainstream media I'm not
saying it's good because it defends it
I'm just saying like there are competing
narratives barely out there barely if at
all
not on not on what matters that's what
I'm saying so like when it comes to
material issues like no you're right it
they don't really like disagree that
much but
there is a weird like war of symbols
uh where you know the the liberal
mainstream media is nominally supposed
to be pro-blm and pro anti-fat antifa
and then like the Fox News is and the
more right-wing crazies are gonna but
still so anyway they're they're I'm just
until there's violence the second that
there's violence then even like what I
don't know what you call liberal like
CNN they're still gonna be like can you
believe that they set this Wendy's on
fire why would they do this did they
think this is gonna further their goal
or make them look bad like look at
you're right you're right well yeah like
it's the illusion it creates it's really
good at creating the illusion that
there's different perspectives on the
issue because they obviously in the
media is corporatized and there's like
what what is it now what's the count now
like four three two one company that
owns them all whatever it is they
obviously they deploy or arrange of
takes on the situation and they
distribute them through the different
media outlets and then they say look at
the variety of opinions you have to
choose from when really it's all just
like several you know whatever think
tanks whatever that whoever makes
absolutely is deploying them and giving
you the illusion that this is a
multi-sided debate with all this all
these facets but there's always the most
important perspectives that are missing
the really different perspectives it's
just like how neoliberals kind of did it
right back in the 70s they were a bunch
of [__] jokes nobody listened to them
but then they started assembling into
those think tanks and developing Reams
and reams of different policy options
and then when policy makers came to make
their decisions they said well look at
all of these and then there's a couple
others from some other people so then
that gave the illusion that these
neoliberals who are just like a few like
Hayek and freedmen and whoever read them
and I gave the illusion that this was
like a well-informed and a large
represented a large variety of views
when no it really didn't it was just a
bunch of different views generated by a
few very few people I agree with you I'm
just saying that compared to back then
the media narrative both are are
surface and and kind of superficial and
distorted but I'm just saying like the
media narrative was different back then
than it did than it is now probably yeah
more more what we call conservative
today I agree but similarly like without
the if you want to do uh the Occupy
thing which didn't have the uh the race
narrative attached to it it was just a
class narrative then most of the news
then was like
it's right yes these people are are poor
the banks got away with it that's really
bad but what do you what why are you
occupying a park like what are you what
are you hoping to accomplish down here
it did it it did get to that point at
the beginning I remember this actually
at the beginning I feel like the media
attention was really positive
but then as it went on and they kept
occupying and they build their little
like communes and they they started like
kind of caught the people were like what
are you what are you doing like what do
you want they're snapping their fingers
instead of clapping that [__] exactly oh
so cringe all right okay we I find it
extremely crazy we are not gonna end it
on a positive note we are gonna end it
okay critique which is encouraged yeah
so I read you know a lot of the stuff
that I read is going to overlap with
some of the stuff that pill said um I
read this piece called the legacy of the
situationists international
um the production of situations of
creative resistance by Adam Bernard
and it's like one of those academic
articles I think where was it published
something called capital in class I
don't know if that's like a well-known
journal or not first I've heard of it
but I think the article is actually
relatively recent which is one of the
reasons I picked it I think it might be
from
I feel like I want to say like 2008 or
2006 something like that like just not
that long ago um like relatively recent
um and really like the reason I picked
it was because I was interested in some
of the foundational concepts of the
situationists
as it pertains to politics and
Revolution and resistance and it seemed
like this article had some of that to
offer and I think
it did a pretty good job of defining
some terms
you know like pills alluded to uh when
he at the end he was talking about kind
of
the building of new cities this is one
of the things that comes up in this
article which is interesting I think
that it's something called new Babylon
by um what's his name
I don't know if I noted the this is the
person's name but it was like the city
plan basically that was in line with
some situationist ideas
um
but interestingly
I think what the reason why it failed
there was like an internal debate among
the situationist and it's just like to
create a new vision of urbanism
ends up like leading to this situation
where you have someone at the top who's
controlling the plan and it ends up
being kind of unintentionally
authoritarian even though the intent of
the design is to create situations that
will change subjectivity to be towards
being more revolutionary But ultimately
uh one of the critiques at the time when
there's debates about a new vision is
well how are you going to do it and
there's a tension I think internally
it seemed to me from this article about
who's going to decide on the kinds of
situations that will lead to the change
of subjectivity
how are those decisions going to be made
and is that not going to lead to kind of
a vanguardism a little bit a little bit
of like
that there's a group of I guess Elite
this is what I meant when I said that I
think there is Maybe
if you take the the political action
side of actually changing things
concretely some kind of a political
project that's Unified
there is a bit of a problem where you
might have a kind of elitism because you
will have a kind of artistic or like a
kind of director who will coordinate
these kinds of interventions these kinds
of artistic interventions
um and then you have like the
participants who will
you know collectively agree to this
project whatever the case may be what
whether it's something smaller scale
um but then you have the majority which
is the third Group which is going to be
passive Spectators who are going to be
caught up in the construction of a
situation
um and the whole idea I guess behind a
lot of these projects whether it was
this new city
is
um to basically energize the passive
spectator into action right to make the
passive spectator
to cultivate their consciousness
so so this is like one of the this is
like the age-old
leftist problem we have all these ideas
and theories but we have to we have to
be the ones in charge of like Awakening
the dumb
lower class
that's what seems to emerge if you take
seriously like the idea of organizing
and doing something concrete it's like
you're gonna have this hierarchical even
though their goal and this is another
thing that comes up a lot in the article
is you know they want to develop
egalitarian Alternatives that are you
know cooperatives community-based
activities you know they want it to be
very Democratic in nature a lot of it
reminded me of what you like you said
pills I agree with you it it reminded me
a lot of Twitter anarchists right
talking about horizontal power
structures abolishing vertical power
structures like that's what they want
but but then when you're talking about
actually building a project how do you
actually get that done in a way that is
still
and the fact is you are going to have a
passive like the majority of people are
going to be these passive
uh individuals who and the whole idea of
formulating these situations is to
somehow awaken subjectivity I think that
in itself is
an interesting claim like How likely is
it that these things can actually
turn people into active
agents and I think one of the things I
wanted to highlight
and kind of my main line of critique I
think has to do with exactly this
question of passivity and activity
and the idea that it seems like the
situationists have a little bit of Hope
or at least some kind of belief in
principle
that everybody could be as engaged and
interested and want their
their uh subjectivity to be disrupted
and changed so that they're more active
there's like a seems to be a binary
between
the passive citizen citizen person who
is you know a meshed in the spectacle
and is enmeshed in consumer capitalism
and all that bad stuff and then there is
this which might relate to that idea we
were talking about earlier about living
directly
this kind of other person who is engaged
and energized in a new new kinds of
experiments new kinds of social uh
organizations
forms of Engagement that actively negate
and undermine these structures that
repeat
uh the spectacle right and I think
you know the commodity right and I think
that the thing that I I guess like I
don't know if you want me to stop there
and you could comment on what I've said
so far if you want
yeah I I really want a point of
clarification just one is this
because the article was a was it just
looking back and you're offering a
critique with it or was this the
Articles no it was offering a
sympathetic kind of overview of it uh
and this is kind of my critique although
he does
sort of mention in passing a few times
that problem that I initially mentioned
about who's going to decide
that and and it's actually I think he's
talking about it more in the context
of historical background about how I
think the guy who wanted to make that
new Babylon City and GUI Devore had a
disagreement
because of how centralized some of these
City plans like the formulation of the
plans were becoming and there's like an
internal disagreement about that very
process that it would require kind of
centralization
um
so he was mentioning in passing less as
a critique sorry one more question do
you know any details like when they say
City Planning do they mean you know we
have guilds and and communes and like
City centers that are run by groups or
what do they mean like do they mean
tearing down buildings and putting up
new ones what does city mean in this
context so he's talking about someone
named constant
he made this idea of called new Babylon
um and so he when he's talking about
it's like a vision for a large-scale
Utopian city basically commune like
communist yeah yeah is it their new
urbanism
yeah Evan Constance and formulary for a
new urbanism
yeah exactly and I think one of the
things that this author brings up is
just that the project was kind of flawed
because it uh what does he say here
you know constant's Mega structures
created totality Under One Roof but one
that reproduces the same alienating
conditions
of the given Urban landscape they may
have been big and futuristic but they
lacked a critical coherence and were not
commensurate with social practice
practices so like it becomes overly
rationalistic when you like I guess over
determine over plan this like Grand
utopian vision
and then the planners become
in your terms elitist but it's like a
technocratic Vanguard even if they're
serving the Communist Utopia exactly and
even if they're saying they're trying to
change subjectivity I mean if you think
about that
that's weird that you have people at the
top who are like I'm gonna mess with
people's subjectivity to make them right
like I mean even if it's four even if
it's a transformation that's why I do
the CIA Connection in the beginning
because I mean the opposite side
obviously that's fine I mean we need to
do that like like so I think I'm not
someone who I actually am fine with that
in a way because you know I I do think
you need
like agency is a myth like there's gonna
be influences with everything so like I
would rather have influences that lead
to outcomes that we would all prefer
so I'm not totally against them but it's
just a little bit antithetical to the
horizontal
you know radically Democratic
underpinnings is my main thing it's just
inconsistent which maybe it's a stupid
critique I've heard you in the past be
like who cares if it's inconsistent but
yeah well that's that's what that's what
like the the translator and the preface
to the society the spectacle was saying
is like many people have tried to sort
of work out the contradictions in turn
the boards work into a scientific tract
on capitalism and the spectacle and it
just doesn't work because it's
dialectical it continuously incorporates
its own critiques into itself and that's
what it's a critical reason and includes
its own critique it's it's you can't
really do it and it was interesting in
an article I was skimming it was it was
actually won by constant and he was
he was sort of because these are all
like notes from debates and things like
that and he was he was accusing ask her
yarn who we were talking about
uh last week I just skimmed the
beginning of it he said ask your yorn's
attitude towards industrial culture is
naive and according to him imagination
is the prerogative of the isolated
individual so clearly he disagrees with
that imagination is a collective
Endeavor which would seem to
contradict the idea of a kind of
Vanguard but I don't know I I don't
really know the my only connection with
it is like like mid to early Century
marks theories of art is Walter Benjamin
and and that shock right that's the
Awakening of subjectivity in a certain
way is the shock right dadaism perfected
this kind of uh shock treatment of of
art where instead of absorbing you in
contemplation which is the mode that we
regard the spectacle with we regard it
in a mode of distant contemplation
the new art or the the art in the age of
technological reproducibility is
supposed to
become drawn in by the masses the masses
wash over it it becomes massified it
becomes but we used to the problem for
him is that we still look at new forms
of art with old concepts of art so we
look at it with those romantic ideas of
originality and individual genius and
spontaneity and deep truth whereas new
art demands the liquidation wholesale of
all of those Concepts which persisting
will lead to fascist deployments of
the spectacle as in the Triumph of the
will of a reef and Stahl and things like
that that's that's a kind of fascist
deployment of new technologies with
using old aesthetic Concepts and so
dadaism
to film is supposed to give us a kind of
shock treatment that releases us from
that because we have no time to focus we
have no time to contemplate it the
images fire past us like bullets
I don't know that's my only like so if
you're talking about like how it's
supposed to tweak subjectivity right
it's not like classical art where it's
supposed to represent sensory experience
it's supposed to get to higher order
intellectual processes and and tweak
those instead
and so that's sort of its own like
formulate its own conceptual basis in a
certain way in the minds of the masses
who then approach it differently not
from distance and contemplation but by
closing in on it and absorbing it and
becoming the producers themselves I
don't know maybe that was a bad that was
a lot of stuff but that's my only
connection yeah to it Victor can I give
you a a picture that I've been working
on it's not in my picture
but uh
beaudriard's response to
Marxism I guess you could call it so the
Marxist picture
and I could say generally like not marks
himself not necessarily Lenin but you
know in general the Marxist picture when
they're sitting there and critiquing
that there's always this like
the masses are dumb the proletariat is
stupid If Only They knew if only they
just like woke up if we could wake them
up and they could understand what we're
saying
then the world would change like
overnight we could have a revolution and
things would get better
bolgerard in the 80s makes this picture
he's like Mark we've we've been getting
it wrong all along it's not that the
proleta or the masses are ignorant and
oblivious to the fact that they're
ignorant they're they are ignorant and
at the same time they're very arrogant
about it they want to sit there and do
nothing they want to be told what to
think but they want you to come to them
properly and if you if you act like
you're better than them then they're
never going to listen to you anyway so
they don't give a [__] about which movie
wins the Oscars they care about the fun
movie they don't care which they don't
care about the [__] art gallery and
all this hoity-toity snooty [__] yeah
this changed the world oh yes this Opera
was the greatest thing ever written by a
human oh Beethoven's Fifth they don't
give a [__] they're like you have to
come to me so in this sense they're
actually not stupid
I mean they are stupid but by choice
they're stupid and haughty and if you
want to change their mind you have to
like be subservient to them which is why
Marxism never works because you're
always acting like they have to bring
themselves up to you to your level as
opposed to vice versa no I couldn't
agree with that more actually I think
that's I mean yeah that's I think that's
right I think that's a big problem with
uh
not yeah going into the public where it
actually is
uh that's kind of what he was saying
here he makes that distinction between
surviving and living it's it's a little
bit like bear life and like that you
know the distinction that a gambin makes
and it's like
you know the the white lower classes
they the working class whites can live
because they aren't the target of all of
this this repression the black community
can barely even live they can only
survive and so that's why they have to
demand more because more is being denied
them
so but I mean as I don't know maybe
that's a critique of Beaudry Arts
critique it's like yeah the masses know
what they want because they can get what
they want but as soon as they're in a
situation where they're like
very impoverished and almost like the
other in their own home and they can
only barely survive and they can't live
which is to I guess enjoy yourself and
go to the new Avengers movie uh then
then you have to demand more if you
can't do that I don't know I don't know
saying they know what they want because
they can get what they want they can
explore the marketplace and buy what
they want sure that's almost like a
privilege I don't know I mean that's
that's true but I think then you would
at that point be a less than a mass
which is why you would say that's like a
minority view whereas the intellectual
you know the person who's making it
ideas YouTube videos
that person depends on the mass not the
other way around but the person who
makes the intellectual YouTube videos
thinks I'm I'm enlightening the masses
whereas your the fact that you exist is
dependent on the masses so you need to
come to that them with hat in hand and
offer them something uh interesting
enough to
to procure their desire
yeah I guess I should I should wonder
where my all my electronic equipment
came from yeah I mean so I would say
that like so that kind of leads into
like the final Point kind of of my like
critique the Crux of it I suppose is
precisely on this question of activating
the citizenry right activating
subjectivity in the everyday person
right not the people who are interested
in reading situationism right not the
people who are interested in Marxism
like those people are kind of irrelevant
like the real question the real puzzle
that's right listener you are irrelevant
if you're listening to this podcast well
when you're talking about like the
possibilities for revolution you kind of
are like it's really the people who
aren't interested who are the people who
are going to make the difference about
whether a revolution could happen or not
um we're not going to make that
difference so and I think this goes back
to the the question I had about
mediation living life directly in this
article at least this this guy says you
know
the goal is to create you know a new
form of everyday life one where
creativity and authenticity are under
the direction of self-management and not
distorted by the alienating system of
commodity production so I think that's
an appealing end but I think
again going back to where is the regular
everyday person who just wants to watch
The Avengers and doesn't care like where
are they at in that like
and this goes back to my the way I'm
using phenomenology
of habit in my own work I think that a
lot of these views uh so this view of
situationism I think
it seems to Value disruption of
structures uh that Institute a kind of
passivity
so this means that I think they end up
privileging a kind of
um newness
and not novelty and alternatives
and then they end up discounting
sameness and repetition or they at least
see those things as suspicious because
those are the things that are
reproducing the same patterns of power
or they would have to counter that
passivity in some way yeah exactly
exactly but I think I think you should
take the Boatyard Point seriously though
because he's saying they're not passive
they're stupid but on purpose because
they want to be so it's not ignorantly
stupid like oh they're naive they don't
know what's happening they know what's
going on and they choose to be stupid
like do not interrupt my life unless you
got something good for me is an
assertion of strength or even an
assertion of solidarity uh I kind of
disagree with that way of framing okay
because I I don't actually think they're
stupid or I think they're passive but
not stupid so I think that it's not so
much that they're stupid
and not passive but they're passive but
not stupid
if that makes sense I want to watch
Yellowstone you can't tell me I can't
watch [__] Yellowstone [__] you yeah
yeah sure sure that's an active um I
mean I know that feeling though this
this stuff readings things like this
makes me feel stupid and I want I
naturally want to avoid things that make
me feel stupid because that's important
that's important so I think I know the
feeling so the passivity the activity is
not in oh I want to actively watch
Yellowstone but it's more a passivity of
I'm not interested in this stuff that's
going to make me question everything
right I don't want that that's the
passivity the passive the the repetition
and habit you know is that we are gonna
Veer towards things that confirm our
determinacy in our habit bodies in our
structures
and so that's I think where we're always
going to be living most of the time in
our Hobbit body and I think it seems to
me that the situation is Hope
is for the transformation of subjects as
they say you know a new everyday life
where creativity and authenticity and
self-management
are negating these structures of power
that to me is not a realistic thing to
build a Politics on because the majority
people are not interested in having
their habit their habitus being
perpetually questioned and challenged by
disruptions of avant-garde artists
[__] they're not interested in that
they don't [__] want dude I still I
really actually want to change my view
on this from any fair I want to change
my view and say that is an active
avoidance
they know it's
out there they're just I want to have my
[__] barbecue and I don't need any of
this [__] leave me alone unless but I
think the reason why they don't want it
has to do with these structures of our
subjectivity in habit like that that
because there's friction right like we
all know what it feels like to force
ourselves to read something
that goes against the grain that
disrupts the challenges that change like
that's work we are maybe weird in that
we derive some pleasure from that but
most people don't and that's just a fact
of the structure of subjectivity in my
opinion based on my reading of
phenomenology so any politics that
builds is built on perpetually shifting
that into some active negating
questioning authentic never gonna
[__] work a waste of time yeah but
it's fun for us don't interrupt my
complacency right don't like I I'm I'm
happy in my state of being a passive
consumer
yeah I know that's speaking but yeah I
know structure of passivity that can
replace this yeah that is the key to a
political project that'll work
you'll come at me with something better
and I'll switch to your things but until
you come at me with something better
leave me without make it out of yeah
bamboo and beyond meat Burgers I don't
care I want to sit in the chair exactly
exactly exactly
consumer we need a passive leftist
politics
I don't know it's so like I mean it goes
back to a point he makes right like in
this article I read the board saying he
says the economic and psychological
distance between blacks and whites
enables blacks to see white consumers
for what they are and their Justified
contempt for whites develops into a
contempt for Passive consumers in
general
and it's like the the people who don't
have that choice to be the passive
consumer is and and when we do read
these sorts of things and when we try to
force our attention onto these
unsettling situations
it naturally kind of disturbs our our
happy complacency being passive
consumers and people don't like that but
ultimately I guess that's a part of the
populace that you're going to have to
appeal to is because people who have
gently settled into their ways of
consumer life which is not even apart
the rest of it's dependent on yeah
that's the core exactly and I actually
wanted to add I meant to say that that
that's what I meant in a way that
there's an unintentional elitism at the
core of this
the elitism is in the truth that most
people aren't interested in that so if
your politics is built on those people
that leads to an elitism
yeah I can see this episode has done
what most episodes do not do and it's
I'm very much
I think I've shifted
really
I think I've shifted but I do I don't
want to call I still don't want to call
them passive I want to call them
actively stupid
yeah maybe I mean I think there's a
certainly an aspect to that like there
isn't an act there is an activity to the
resistance of people telling you but
I still think ultimately the reason for
that is just because of the way our
subjectivity veers us towards
repetition passivity
same of what we're used to but you could
even bring it into this like I mean I
think you're right there but the pronoun
[__] for example the pronoun [__] like
99 of people have never actually
encountered someone correcting them on
their pronouns that's true these are
these are spaces that I run through and
it's happened to me where I like had to
be corrected maybe once or twice like no
it's they not
and that's probably because you're also
more likely to be around academics too
yeah absolutely and cut that gender
Fearless
gender theorists and fucodians and all
that but the amount of active energy
that is put into talking about pronouns
is immense compared to the actual times
that pronouns become a question ah but I
know why the reason for that is because
of loss aversion which is something that
is also built into our habit bodies that
like if you can convince and this there
might be you might need to bring in
psychoanalysis also to like ex to offer
a robust account of this
but I think people are motivated when
they can they perceive a fear that
something is going to be taken away from
them
so the conservatives who are being
fear-mongered to about these pronouns
they are wow I'm gonna have to live in a
world where I'm gonna have to be more
active and think about the pronoun all
the time [__] that oh you mean so so I
will actively be against it they'll put
in the energy now to avoid it later to
defend their passivity to defend their
pre-existing passivity they will defend
I gotta say I still think there's we
should keep talking about this uh at a
later time but the active passivity
uh binary that we're drawing I think it
needs to be reframed some part of it
needs to be refined I agree I I agree
that's something that I'm struggling
with in my own work actually of how to
frame that
that that that that that difference but
I think there is some difference there
but I think that when you talk about it
in those terms
something is kind of being lost or
distorted or mystified so you might be
able to think of it in terms of uh
systems theory and like you want to you
don't want to change the logic of
decision making you do want to keep
making decisions but you don't want to
change the mechanisms or the track that
decisions are made
yeah so you'll fight you'll expend a
hell of a lot of energy to keep the
track the same
that's a good way of putting it actually
even if it's I'd like to I just before
we sign off too and I had another
thought on an earlier critique
that Victor made
um about the direct living Direction
yeah what was it like real directly
authenticity all that stuff kind of and
I I keep thinking the way to frame this
is being unalienated because I think
and what what I think you know like the
althazarian influenced marxists
who
the new who tend to be mistrustful of
young Marx and his ideas about like the
Marxist humanist
Uh current of Marx's thought right where
a lot of them hold out like lefebv right
lefebv was an influence on Deborah in
the situation it's a big one they I
think he studied with the Fab and
lefeb's idea which he says he says um
the transformation of everyday life the
the impetus behind this maximalism came
from the idea of the transformation of
everyday life lefeb's idea of total man
that is the unalienated man
and I think
unalienated would be that direct living
like that's what it would be and and I
think the structuralist marxists have
the problem with that and the
psychoanalytic
lacanian inflected marxists have a
problem with that is because we cannot
like alienation separation is
constitutive of subjectivity it's not a
it's not just like you're a total person
or you're you're developing development
towards a total subject is somehow
interrupted you know it's it's not an
option you got to be alienated yeah so
they'd say it's just how unalienated man
is an impossible thing and that like
whatever you think about the 1844
humanist papers or the whatever
Luxembourg and like the the Marxist
humanists yeah that's I think that would
be a major critique as well just picking
up on what you're saying earlier I think
that's how I thought to frame it maybe
no I agree with that I think that's
that's well put I've kind of thought
about it in somewhat similar I think
also being uh very sympathetic to look
on
it's also something I've thought about
uh just in general like that concept of
alienation and even yeah the spectacles
throughout the concept of alienation
from uh like the capitalist critique of
it then before that you got two thousand
years of Christian alienation where your
entire life is spent trying to be
unaliated to the community of God and
God himself who you've sinned against
and then you go back before that and go
oh yeah the I mean a bunch of people do
this as well the Greeks they had it
right the Greeks had had their like
little segments where
each part was ruined or ruled by a
character and that was less alienated
but you know I mean that's too it's too
far from our imagination to imagine
whether or not that was [__] wasn't
it wasn't it wasn't Socrates arguing in
effect about how like the The Poets the
gods at the time were I mean he
certainly didn't use the language of
alienation but talked about there's a
reason why he wanted to get rid of them
to get closer to the truth or something
of the closer to the good yeah they were
too they were bad role models
or even just the legacy of like the
utopian thinking the philanderies and
and utopianism and Charles Fourier and
and I mean that's a picture of kind of
unalienated harmonious life even like
the caricatures of just living off the
land in some kind of pastoral hippie
commune right like you're just like in
sync with nature you're in tune you're
you're taking exactly as much as your
needs and like you're in a community and
everybody's sort of feeding off of each
other like those even those like crazy
radical experiments in the 60s like
searching for and I I don't know I think
the situationists have a version of that
which is basically to hunt down and
eliminate alienation wherever it could
be found and the spectacles the great
purveyor of it I mean it's maybe it's
maybe that would be one way to think
about their kind of living directly is
gone well it's like well it was never
there in the first place that's kind of
um
An Origin story you've made for yourself
that just otherwise I always feel like
uh
I feel like my politics is like
we just need a better alienation and we
need better passivity
yeah like like it's not about getting
rid of those things it's just about
having better ones
in my opinion yeah something like that
maybe we can reframe the active passives
yeah for next time and uh and uh think
about that some more yeah those those
fun yeah we'll have to Workshop it but
for now
we're at an over an hour and a half so
yeah exactly we should wrap up first but
good good thank you guys for uh this is
a good format it's uh we're gonna have
to reuse it
yeah I was a little nervous about it
because I thought it would be
disconnected but I think somehow like it
worked out pretty well it seems even
with articles that were somewhat
different like Eric's was different but
I thought it fit you know natural
natural sounding Segways is very much a
skill of of podcasting that I think we
might have gotten good at without even
realizing that we did yeah hopefully
yeah courtesy of this website too who's
hosting at Virginia Tech is that who's
hosting this um situationist archive
yeah cool in English check the check the
link below all right take care you guys
we'll see you next week or sound here at
you next week whatever it is yep cheers
till then have a situation yeah
construct all right
[Music]